we're about to watch every harry potter
movie well scenes from harry potter
movies and i'm going to critique them
from the eyes and lens of a doctor you
ready
let us begin the sorcerer's stone i just
spit
harry potter
that's hagrid
and that's dumbledore i remember their
names good luck
harry potter oh that that's an
interesting scar you know what's funny
i've watched harry potter as a kid never
thought about this before went to
medical school residency and now i see
it i think
harry was treated by a bad plastic
surgeon who was trying to practice
z-plasty z-plasty is what happens when
you try and make a scar look less
visible when you cut a scar in a shape
of a z you can actually
change its appearance to blend in more
when it heals when it blends in better
with the skin lines isn't that cool
[Music]
see i feel like if you're riding a broom
for the first time it should be just
like riding a bike you need to wear a
helmet clearly they don't have doctors
family medicine doctors doing counseling
at this school
[Music]
everyone out of the way
okay that's a high velocity fall i would
say it's a fall from probably 12 feet
that requires emergency 911 help you
need to stabilize the c-spine get a
c-collar on there if you have a fracture
in the cervical collar you could
potentially cause paralysis
oh dear it's a broken wrist it's a
broken wrist that's it maybe do a full
body check like when a patient comes in
from a trauma we check the entire body
we just cut off all the clothes because
we need to see everything the last thing
we want to find out is that there's like
a huge cut from the broomstick inside
his abdomen he's bleeding out and we
didn't check because we're going ooh
look at his wrist most commonly broken
bone in the wrist scaphoid you got it
good job falling out stretched hand
i feel like i need a trauma specialist
watching this with me i'm scared for all
of their bodies
see so that fall while looking terrible
and at high velocity did not look as bad
to me as a medical professional i'll
explain because he fell with momentum
carrying him forward and inertia he
actually did not come to a sudden stop
therefore the force and the impact on
his body wasn't as bad so that's why a
lot of times like when people survive
skydiving accidents it's because they
landed on a hill and were able to
continue falling down
what is that
that's what i say
when patients misbehave are you okay no
i think
it's either
a radial fracture or an ulnar fracture
based on the location
oh it looks like he got rid of his bones
if you don't have any bones in there you
can't really make use of the hand and
then you could potentially damage all
your blood vessels and nerves there i
can mend bones in a heartbeat but
growing them back you will be able to
won't you oh i'll be able to certainly
but it'll be painful growing bones back
that's something new maybe we'll have
that in the future there's actually a
conditioned fibular hemimelia where the
the fibula of the lower leg is short and
we could actually do some procedures to
help it grow limb lengthening is
actually a legitimate procedure
[Music]
dragon
i've never experienced the dragon bite
in the hospital basilisk a basilisk
dragon what's the difference between a
basilisk
i've never seen a basil skinjury in the
hospital there was someone who had like
a komodo dragon bite which resulted in
salmonella i think
yeah i'm pretty sure salmonella is the
bacteria that's found on lizard tongues
that like or teeth that you need to be
careful for
oh that's definitely one way to kill a
basilisk go right for the base of the
basilisk skull
a tooth to the forearm radial ulnar
artery
he better put some pressure on that bad
boy or a tourniquet if it's bleeding
badly because he's not going to survive
long otherwise and there must be
salmonella on this basilisk tooth watch
like another doctor do a reaction video
dr mike shares misinformation there's no
salmonella on vascular teeth i've looked
into it i read the research on facebook
[Music]
of course
phoenix tears have healing powers
so all you got to do to heal yourself of
cancer is to make a phoenix cry who knew
we probably don't need oncologists
anymore we probably don't need many
doctors anymore we just need a bunch of
fena
phoenicians phoenicies phoenicians
[Music]
are you watching this video with your
doctor mike merchant come on where's
your pee whoop stuff it's linked right
below by the way i got my own
invisibility cloak
[Music]
now if there's a
tibetan
turnip
that will allow me to breathe underwater
for an hour then great
but otherwise i don't know about turnip
but you can always use ghillie weed you
know the army actually tested a
substance that you could take in your
mouth and allow you to breathe
underwater for longer periods of time
but there are techniques you could use
to hold your breath for a really long
time underwater
you're sure about this neville
absolutely for an hour most likely is he
taking performance-enhancing drugs so
he's cheating
[Music]
he literally just became a newfoundland
newfoundlands rescue people pull them
out of water by multiples they have
webbed beats they can doggy panel like
champs
he's going up way too high there's like
legitimate decompression sickness that
he's potentially gonna get barotrauma
all of the above really and for those
who don't know like when you breathe
water uh when you breathe underwater
usually with the scuba said not their
gills uh and you breathe in air like
let's say 10 meters down 33 feet down
and then you ascend too quickly that air
expands it could damage your lungs
of the father
unwillingly
given
flesh
the servant
willingly
sacrificed
oh
my man just completely cut off his hand
i mean he's not surviving for longer
than five to ten minutes on this one
you're gonna exsanguinate bleed out i
mean there have been like cases where if
you have a really clean cut maybe if
your wounds are cauterized maybe if your
blood vessels spasm like crazy you can
stop the bleeding or if you put on a
tourniquet but like my guy here doesn't
look medically responsible if you know
what i'm saying
is this voldemort
oh
where's his nose with a nose like that
you're gonna have trouble warming air up
you're gonna have trouble cleaning the
air because you have less cilia because
your nose doesn't protrude out as much
he wouldn't do well in antarctica
skiving snack boxes sweets that make you
ill get you out of class whenever you
like obtain hours of pleasure from a
profitable boredom
care for another are those candies that
literally get kids sick so they don't
have to do their activities that's
terrible i'm trying to weigh what's
worse that or vaping and i feel like
they're both equally as bad
this place has known magic
why is everyone why would you cut like
you need blood cool it's a movie but you
cut
the most painful most most nerve endings
are here
why would you cut the most painful place
cut like the upper area of your arm like
where you get the flu shot or something
hurry quickly in my bag
there's a bottle labeled essence of
bitterness
my
those are some serious lacerations to
the arm in the arm you have the axillary
artery which becomes the brachial artery
you cut that you're bleeding out very
very quickly especially from the left
side near the heart i don't know what
she's spraying on it like there's no way
that's helping put some pressure on it
stop it from bleeding hermione please
for god's sakes dobby has come to save
harry potter and his friends
[Music]
why'd you pull it out of him it was
creating pressure and actually
preventing him from bleeding out he
needs to call 9-1-1 harry you've been a
good and faithful servant severus
but only i can live
forever not if you go to antarctica
because your nose doesn't have
turbinates in it so you probably can't
warm up the air and humidify it well
oh yeah if you're gonna cut the carotids
you're gonna bleed out like there's no
saving that person
[Music]
see smart he's checking for a pulse
before starting chest compressions if he
has a pulse no need to do chest
compressions
harry if he's going unconscious and he
has no pulse you best better start chest
compressions
is he a fish he looks like a fish
because he has like like gill-like
protrusions in his skull the nose he's
like a snake fish a catfish no eel fish
he's an eel
did harry potter just take away this
elderly gentleman's walking cane
that's obviously
you know terrible medical condition that
you don't want to have your skin float
away
into the ether micro punctuation of the
skin
into the atmosphere
check out this patient's story when a
patient of mine got misdiagnosed over
and over again simply because of his
weight click here to check that out as
always stay happy and healthy i'm
putting a spell on you stay happy and
healthy and watch this video
[Music]